familienalltag im krieg sergej wohnt mit
seinen zwei söhnen und seiner frau im
südwesten kirst hier wollen sie bleiben
der neunjährige sohn kirillow hatte bis
vor kurzem sogar noch schulunterricht
[Musik]
letzte woche hat er das vierte schuljahr
beendet und alle prüfungen bestanden
jetzt kann er eigentlich machen was
immer er möchte er spielt computergames
schaut sich cartoons an sie spielen
videospiele zusammen wir lesen ihnen vor
sie lesen selbst spielen mit lego
eine scheinbare normalität die beim
anblick solcher zerstörungen ihrer stadt
kaum zu begreifen ist
und trotz aller bemühungen der krieg
bestimmt immer wieder das leben der
familie sirenen explosionen nachrichten
über noch mehr tote
vor allem der ältere will oft in den arm
genommen werden braucht mehr
aufmerksamkeit als am anfang des krieges
er erzählt uns dass er oft holen muss
natürlich versuchen wir ihn zu trösten
fast jeden abend verschanzen sie sich
zum schlafen in den hausflur außerhalb
der wohnung die dicken wände sollen
besser vor raketen schützen gerade in
den letzten tagen nahmen die angriffe in
kiew wieder zu und damit auch ihre angst
dann war diese explosion die ganz kiew
gehört hat als sie eine bombe auf ein
einkaufszentrum fallen ließen das war
unglaublich laut es vermittelt ein
gefühl von lebensgefahr und panik dass
du einfach nicht sicher bist
und seine frau alina versuchen ihre
ängste vor den kindern zu verbergen und
stattdessen schöne momente zu schaffen
ein paar kilometer weiter haben diese
jungs und mädchen in einer kirche
zuflucht gefunden sie sind aus der
heftig umkämpften stadt hennef geflohen
pastor anatoli hat seine christliche
freikirche in ein riesiges hilfszentrum
umfunktioniert von hier aus schicken sie
lebensmittel medizin und vieles mehr in
besonders betroffene gebiete des landes
auf dem rückweg nehmen sie geflüchtet
damit
warum wir das alles machen weil jesus
auch so gehandelt hat jesus hat sich um
die menschen gekümmert wie könnte ich
jetzt also nur an mich denken ich bleibe
hier in kiel ich liebe mein land ich
liebe meine leute ich tue für sie was
immer ich kann
der 67 jährige will den familien vor
allem den kindern ein leben in
sicherheit ermöglichen sie raus aus dem
krieg holen
[Musik]
gott sei dank sie sind noch am leben
jenny hof wurde stark bombardiert letzte
woche es befindet sich nahe der
russischen grenze dort ist es sehr
gefährlich
jetzt geben wir ihnen etwas zu essen
platz für die kinder und alles was sie
brauchen
sie sind ein paar stunden hier dann
werden wir sie in den westen bringen
einfach in sicherheit der kleine viktor
hat diese chance nicht sag mal es lebe
die ukraine viktor ist eines von 20
babys die auf ihre eltern warten von der
klinik in den bomben keller von kiew
gebracht es sind babys von leihmüttern
natalia ist so eine leihmutter obwohl
sie keine bindung zu ihrem kind aufbauen
soll hat sie es nicht übers herz
gebracht es hier zu lassen mitten im
krieg sie hat bereits fünf eigene kinder
erzählt sie rund 15.000 euro hat sie für
das baby bekommen doch nur des geldes
wegen habe sie es nicht gemacht
kein geld der welt kann das bezahlen
wenn du einer familie die keine kinder
haben kann ein neues menschliches leben
schenkt
sie haben chinesische kanadische und
auch deutsche eltern die in der heimat
verzweifeln wie können sie ihr baby no
aus dem krieg holen mit natalia
versorgen 7 kindermädchen die babys rund
um die uhr
hier schlafen wir hier sind wir mit den
kindern wir sind hier eine familie
wir machen uns gemeinsam sorgen
unterstützen uns gegenseitig
hunderte leihmütter warten allein in
kiew auf die geburt ihrer kinder
leihmutterschaft ist in der ukraine
legal ein umstrittenes geschäft mit den
babys nun haben viele mit ihren
ungeborenen kindern das land verlassen
es gibt welche die sind weg manch einer
hat angst bekommen ja es gab solche aber
die die geblieben sind sind sich der
verantwortung für die kinder bewusst
ihre eigenen kinder mussten sie mitten
im krieg bei den großeltern oder
verwandten lassen um die neugeborenen
babys zu beruhigen
die noch nicht begreifen dass um sie
herum zerstörung und leid herrscht
natalias baby soll bald abgeholt werden
die verzweifelten eltern aus kanada
seien schon in der ukraine
sie hofft dass es im frieden aufwächst
im frieden aufwachsen das wünscht sich
auch sehr für seine kinder gleichzeitig
macht sich der vater sorgen wie
gefährlich ist es in kiew zu bleiben
jede stunde jedes mal wenn du die
sirenen höheren fragen wir uns tun wir
noch das richtige
solange kein zweites archiv oder mario
pohl ist wollen sie die stadt nicht
verlassen
wir wollen dass unsere kinder spüren
dass das leben weitergeht ja da draußen
gibt es ein risiko aber du musst nicht
zwingend davon laufen nur weil die panik
ist
sie gehen zum friseur
sie freuen sich über frische croissants
serie arbeitet weiter als it-berater sie
trotzen der angst sie trotzen dem feind
und halten an ihrer unabhängigkeit fest
[Musik]
auch pastor anatoli will kiew auf keinen
fall verlassen er glaubt an den sieg der
ukraine er glaubt an den frieden denn
letztendlich so sagt er liege diese
stadt das ganze land und die menschen
allein in gottes händen